[Music]
all right so we'll get into it thank you
so much for the introduction there rob
uh as you mentioned i worked on the
customer success team here at our studio
uh the basic idea is that i work with
our professional customers
to best use our professional products as
well as open source packages
in their specific environment so i spend
a lot of time
thinking about kind of integrating open
source with professional products
you know using data science at scale in
production kind of in your own
environment
and our studio connect is really one of
the key
players at least of ours in that field
of getting your data science products
kind of off your laptop
into production and ready for
consumption in your organization
so quick overview today's agenda i'll
give you an overview
connect an overview of how our markdown
plays together with connect and then do
a quick
demo of some of the examples i'm showing
today
there's a lot of material here that
we've kind of already covered with
other topics so specifically i'll be
focusing on our markdown
but if you're just interested in using
kind of our studio products in
production there's actually a webinar on
that
there's model management shiny and
production as well as
art studio team quick start where you
can actually try out connect without
installing anything so maybe you think
this is interesting want to
see what it looks like on your own
environment try it out there
and lastly the solutions.ourstudio.com
website will be
hosting a lot of the examples i used
today and that was intentional
in terms of i want you to be able to see
some of the code that i'm using
so that you can understand uh just how
quickly you could go from
using something locally to putting it
out there
so again our studio connect kind of what
it is is a content hub and execution
engine for all your data
data products so this could be things
like web apps machine learning models as
restful apis
dashboards reports automatic emails or
custom emails
tables and visualizations basically
anything you're already creating an r
it makes it where you can take those
insights and leverage them
a little bit faster so you can
you know share it widely uh share it
securely just you know get it off your
local environment and put it out there
for your organization to actually use
and uh importantly rc connect is fully
interoperable so
it will play with any of the data
products you can make in r and
additionally
it can communicate with things like r
and python or r and spark
javascript tensorflow sql all these
things can be integrated
into the data products you're creating
so you have a nice platform to push out
all these things that you're making
the basic idea of what it would look
like in your environment and this is
just a very simple example
is you create something locally maybe on
your desktop in our studio ide
or on rstudio server or studio server
pro you then have push button deployment
to push
whatever you create say a shiny
application or our markdown document
onto connect connect will then host it
it will provide all the scaling and
security you need
it can connect to your file share system
it can connect to your databases
and ultimately your end users will just
access that content via their own web
browser
so they really just kind of see it as a
website but in reality
it's a hosted on-premise solution for
your group
it could also be hosted on the cloud but
the idea being that
you install the software wherever you
want it to be and you have full access
and control over its own security
now this being said this is a relatively
simple example
and when people start talking about
production you start thinking of these
massive kind of environments whether
it's thousands of users
or you know lots of people hitting your
api calls or
you know just doing things at scale and
so for a lot of people
production is kind of this buzzword or
this idea
of you know putting things into
production is scary for a lot of people
and so i kind of want to go over uh how
at least i think about
production environments and kind of how
we approach this with connect and how
you can kind of
start where you are maybe you're more
advanced maybe you're less advanced and
kind of grow within connect
so what does production mean to me i'll
steal a quote from joe chang that he
gave at the most recent rstudio conf
production means a software environment
that is used and then relied upon by
real users with real consequences that
things go wrong
so specifically you know this doesn't
talk about how big the environment is it
doesn't talk about how widely it's used
just something the business relies upon
something the business is using to
either make decisions or to gain insight
about some data science product
that's really the ultimate goal of data
science is to inform a business decision
to provide value of some type for the
organization or for the individual
beyond kind of that basic idea in my
mind there's some other production needs
so things like scaling and execution you
know you want to have it be able to work
for your entire organization if you
wanted to as opposed to just
locally on your own laptop you want to
have security and access control
so you don't wanna just put it out there
for everyone on the internet to access
and even within your own group maybe you
wanna have uh only execs
see these specific uh materials or only
your data science group see
other material you also want to have
logging and visibility into the
applications you've already pushed out
there or the things you're using
in production as well as logging about
the performance or when they've been
updated or
changes that have been made and as
garrett covered in the last webinar
reproducibility is also a huge component
and with a code based solution like r
you're really focusing on being able to
reproduce
both that environment as well as the
actual code that you've used to create
your asset
and lastly something i think is really
important is the sharing and
collaboration idea
so sharing in terms of you're creating
something you you worked
and spent a lot of time on creating a
model or evaluating a model
making some type of prediction you know
doing some core data science tasks
and then ultimately you have to inform
somebody or share that with somebody
and have a useful discussion with them
additionally you want to have
collaboration with them so maybe
you know you have to send reports back
and forth or collaborate back and forth
with someone who
doesn't use r but they're making big
decisions but they may not be a coder
so being able to bring them into the
fold and give them an asset that they
can work with and the last part of that
sharing collaboration aspect is kind of
discoverability so
being able to you know go into your your
area and find things of interest that
may be useful for your team to make
decisions
ultimately the kind of the idea here is
production doesn't have to be as scary
as you want it as
it kind of always comes out to be so yes
there are some environments that are
extremely locked down extremely complex
they're serving
thousands and thousands of users and you
know just
a lot goes into it from a devops
standpoint there's other people who
really just want to take some type of r
based product and put it out there for
five to ten people
and the kind of the concept here is that
i have customers on both ends of the
spectrum you know very small groups
serving
other small groups and other people who
are serving you know
hundreds or thousands of individuals
within their organization
and connect kind of works for both of
these groups as well as kind of the
spectrum across them
so in terms of what connect provides
this uh concept
is kind of hitting on the same points
that i said before so
scaling execution high availability
basically you can take your
your shiny application your mark down
and scale it out to your organization
additionally because connect can
actually execute our code
it can actually re-run uh your r scripts
or our markdown documents or your shiny
applications
for for new people as far as the high
availability concept you can have
multiple connect servers kind of in a
cluster
so if you know part of your server were
to go down you have another one ready to
go
or if you just want to share the load
across multiple servers that's also
possible
additionally you have full security
access control and visibility so you can
bring your own
you know ldap active directory saml
security to authenticate users you have
access control
so at the application your server level
you can you know specify who can see
what
as well as you know have applications
that are only for
testing or only for production use and
lastly you have full visibility
uh in terms of you can see what's been
published there and you can kind of
understand what's being used in your
organization
additionally from the reproducibility
logging standpoint i'll cover this a
little bit later but
you have these kind of sandbox
environments on connect where you
publish something
it you know tracks the r environment and
tracks all the different packages that
are being used
so you have this kind of metadata about
the assets you're creating
you also have logging about both use of
it and updates to those assets
and lastly you have full sharing
collaboration so
yes you can now take our mock-down
document and just you know publish the
finished document
out onto connect and then people can
access it via web browser which is a
huge win for a lot of people
but additionally it opens up as an
execution engine where
those people who may not know how to
code can actually re-execute those are
markdown documents or shiny applications
uh to create something they want to see
without ever having to
you know go and bother the data
scientists directly
and lastly you have the collaboration
and discoverability you can actually
search around or connect and find things
of interest
ultimately connects getting your data
products off your laptop and ready for
consumption
in your environment
again when i talked about security you
have kind of three major levels of
security that i like to focus on
so your server level just authenticated
users accessing your content so you can
bring your own kind of security
a lot of people are familiar with active
directory ldap saml there's some other
ones there but those are the three big
players we see
you also have app level so you can
restrict user access to your
applications
whether they're shiny or markdown kind
of going in there
and filtering out who needs to see what
and lastly you can even have data level
access to specific things even within an
application so
all these different tiers of security
and access that you like to see
in your production environment
as far as the reproducibility i hit on
this a little bit earlier
but the the big idea here is that you
really
you know don't want to create something
put it out there and then all of a
sudden not have
governance or understanding of how you
created it
uh so you don't want to lose the code
you don't want to lose
the information about which package
version you were on or which version of
r you were on
or what were the even the system
dependencies that you were using there
so importantly the way that connect
works is
you create an asset locally so maybe
it's on a server through our studio
server
or on the desktop ide so you write an
application you're creating our markdown
document whatever you're doing
you actually bundle that together when
you click publish
so this is all done automatically you
just click publish
connect will bundle all that information
together so you have the source code
you have the metadata around the
specific dependencies that's pushed out
to connect
connect then unpacks the bundle with
this packret bundle
and it actually reinstalls the specific
dependencies at the exact package
version you're using so the same version
of our the same version
of the exact packages you're using so
you have this kind of you know
sandboxed environment of exactly what
you want it to be
importantly each data product has its
own r environment so this prevents
breaking existing deployed content
you can have multiple versions of r
basically running
across your different assets multiple
different package versions running
across your different assets if you
wanted to
uh we have a little bit more information
here in the documentation
uh in the admin guide about package
management and if you'd like to know
more about package manager we can also
have that discussion
the next step i'd like to cover is the
deployment aspect
so when people talk about you know
pushing to pride you know the joke is
always don't do
you know don't push anything out on
friday afternoon you don't want to
you know just put something out there
into the world and then disappear for
the weekend
so people will think very differently
about
how they're publishing or how they're
deploying assets
into their production environment for a
group just starting out you know they're
ecstatic and super excited about just
doing push button deployment you know
just being able to
create something locally and basically
in a few seconds publish it out and have
it ready to go and share it across your
entire group
other groups are very much more about
the governance and the devops side where
they want to have
kind of man in the middle or a woman in
the middle just someone
there who is making a decision about is
this ready to go to productions maybe
that means code review
or putting it into git or continuous
integration
so i'll cover all these options briefly
the first option would be just push
button deployment which is the default
so within the ide you can actually click
this little blue button and it will
publish things onto connect at that
point you could still restrict access so
maybe you want to push it out
play around with it on connect and only
you can access it at this point
and then after the fact you could uh you
know say okay well this is running well
i'll ask allow access to the rest of our
audience and kind of open it up to
uh the rest of the group to kind of use
the data product
alternatively you could put things out
through git so you could have a get back
deployment where you're not going to
push button deployment anymore but
rather you're actually you know pushing
something out into version control
through git
and then connect is kind of calling out
to get and installing it directly from
there
so in this case you publish it out our
studio connect will publish the initial
version
and they will actually update pulling
different you know git updates
onto connect itself
on the alternative side rather than
having kind of this one-step
process you could have a testing and
then a production environment
or what we like to call kind of a
staging and then a production
environment
so in this case you actually publish
your asset initially into
a kind of a sandbox staging or testing
environment so a different version of
connect
and only your kind of devops your data
science team is accessing at this point
you're just you know dog fooding it
testing it making sure things are rock
solid
once it's gone through that stage you
can then redeploy it onto your
production environment and let the rest
of your consumers use it now that you
know that
you know it's working properly so this
would be a little bit more complex but
in reality
you're still able to use the same kind
of push button deployment here
alternatively you can the same idea
where you're pushing things out into a
sandbox doing your user approval and
testing
but after this you actually will ask it
to publish into production so now you're
bringing in an additional stakeholder
because you want to have more governance
or you want to have more
insight into you know bringing in the
rest of the administration team here
and they will actually then publish it
into production um
all these are valid ideas but because
the concept here i'm trying to cover
is that connect is kind of ready to
serve all these different environments
or kind of approaches and lastly another
one would be continuous integration
so still doing your sandboxing your
testing approval
and then the request is actually sent to
merge into your you know version control
it goes through code review it's pushed
out to the master branch
and then a continuous integration server
will actually uh publish its production
itself so something like you know
jenkins will go out there
pull the code that's been updated and
then republish it on to connect
you know going through this relatively
quickly just again the idea that
wherever you are kind of in your data
science journey connect is ready to meet
you at that point
getting more kind of off of the
administration side
and quickly into the data product side
again i mentioned i'd be covering a lot
of our markdown
a lot of people are familiar with our
markdown kind of on their local
environment
writing reports you know maybe creating
a blog or
even creating small websites uh
and the idea being that you can create
all these things but then where are you
going to put them and connect can be
that place
obviously you can also host things like
shiny applications which has been
covered in other webinars
or even putting a model into production
as a restful api
which has also been covered in another
link that i shared in this webinar
but the idea here is that you know you
have a spectrum
of you know interactivity with your
documents and garrett covered this
really well
last week so i stole this slide from him
kind of the idea of
you have this spectrum of more
interactivity so a local rmd
that you're working in interactively and
then you knit at once
and so it's not really interactive maybe
you have an
r d with parameters so now you can
create many reports from a single master
report
you could add an html widget for
front-end interactivity that doesn't
require
and gives you all this you know uh kind
of fancy
shiny-esque uh environment or kind of
interactivity
but you don't have to have it hosted
with a shiny back-end
and then you could you know fully put a
shiny component onto it so have a flex
dashboard
or our markdown based source with shiny
runtime
you've got a server in the back end that
gives you full further interactivity
and then all the way out to a shiny
application which could be a truly
custom web app so not necessarily a
report or a dashboard
but you know truly something that you
just created yourself
now the idea being that i'm going to
focus uh kind of on the first three
points here you know
basic arm markdowns are markdowns
parameters and arm reference with html
widgets
specifically on our studio connect
and this is why i like to think about it
as our markdown in production you know
not just using our markdown as you know
your basic reporting just for yourself
but thinking of our markdown
as like a key player in your data
science environment and in your data
science
kind of production environment where
you're using our markdown
as a way to create
you know repeated jobs or reports or
automated emails all these different
things that can provide value for your
company that you may not be using today
so the basic idea of an arm markdown
report again i'll just cover it briefly
in case you missed last week's webinar
it's an
open source r package that produces high
production quality
documents by integrating pros with cold
code and results
basically you can write you can create
code and you can create outputs all
within a single document
so this is really useful for data
scientists who are already using r
and they want to both create a report
and share the report in a reproducible
way
it can create all sorts of different
output formats everything from basic
documents
pdf journals uh full-blown web pages
word docs um other our markdown formats
uh you can do presentations whether
they're kind of outpost pdf or as an
html
output dashboards through flex
dashboards uh
full websites or blogs or you know
knowledge repos and then also full books
importantly all these different output
formats can actually be published and
hosted on connect
so you can actually publish the finished
product as well as
bundle the code and the finished product
where it can actually be re-executed on
connect without having to write
additional code
get to the next one there we go uh so
with primaritized reports
uh kind of taking the next step from our
markdown kind of the idea here is that
you take a single
or markdown write a function around it
and then you can
loop through or use a map function from
per
to create multiple versions of this
report so this is just kind of a fake
report i put together
the idea here is that you're rendering a
specific our markdown document
you're listing some parameters so these
parameters tell you that
state and year for it will be generated
kind of
on the fly based off behind your inputs
and then you're creating this output
file
as an html output so you write this
function
uh you you kind of specify your inputs
so there's four different inputs here
four different uh four states repeated
and then multiple years
and then you can knit uh this report
locally four different times
so this is really powerful in terms of
you can create multiple reports on your
local environment
really quickly based off the same code
the next step with rstudio connect is
you can take this same primarized report
publish onto connect with the source
code and someone who doesn't have r
installed on their local machine or
doesn't even know how to you know
code in r and they're actually able to
have a user interface to
basically re-knit this report with
parameters of interest
so you can take the same parameters and
put a front end on it
you can also use things like html
widgets which i mentioned before is
front end interactivity so those do not
require a server backend so you could
publish
our markdown document with say the
leaflet package which provides
a javascript and html on the front end
we're able to interact and kind of get
this kind of google maps ask but it's
really open street map
um interactivity around on maps
there's a ton of different html widgets
and even things like crosstalk where you
can have html widgets talk to each other
on the same web page even without a
server you could always add a server on
the back end with shiny runtime
but these three links here will cover
additional
html widgets that i won't get to today
and lastly something of interest and
something that i'm really excited about
is the blastula package
which is a way of creating uh beautiful
html
uh emails uh in our and in rmds
so the basic idea is that you can write
a basic
you know script or almost like a an r
markdown
format here of what you want the email
to say
it can then run the uh this email based
off of some r input
and have an output of this beautiful
html
email that can then be pushed out
through connect automatically
so yes you could create a report that
people can interact with you could also
have that same report kind of
copy pasted into an email and sent to a
specific person even if they're not
accessing connect
and so these three things here are
something i'm going to cover on the the
demo portion which i'll get over to here
in a second
and lastly there is this link here where
kelly o'brien actually put together an
example of custom scheduled emails with
blastula and our studio connect
it's a great read through with this i'd
like to jump over into the demonstration
point
so let me switch screens
zoom in a little bit
all right so for most people hopefully
this is familiar
uh in terms of this is the uh
our studio ide importantly i'm actually
accessing this through my web browser
so this is rstudio server pro
you could technically use the desktop
ide and get the same
kind of experience with publishing so
the idea here is that i create an
application
if i want to publish it i can publish it
to connect here
by just clicking this blue publish
button i take
all the source code the it finds the
data that is necessary to run this
uh bundles it all together and says do
you want to publish it now i've actually
published this already so i would be
updating an existing asset
but i would just click publish and it
would push all that and reinstall the
packages onto colorado which is our
internal
connect server but the idea here is that
that's it that's push button deployment
you know one button press you're ready
to go and it's pushed out there
um this example here is a shiny
application
this could be our markdown for html
this could be our markdown for a pdf
document
um or it could be even a zerengine uh
mood reader or
zarinkin for a a presentation uh with
you know html css on the front end
so this application will just go through
the shiny app first i publish it on to
connect
the basic landing page for connect gets
me here so
the immediate thing of interest is that
you have your discoverability built in
i can see all the content i own i could
also
filter back out and just look at all the
server content
um you know going in and even searching
for maybe i just want to look for pdfs
i can search for pdf documents and find
you know things that have been added to
pdf
i also have a full-blown tagging system
so internally we do this around
technologies but you can imagine a world
where
in your environment you actually want to
filter it out by specific teams or by
specific assets
but the idea being that you could filter
at many different levels
and and find content that is meaningful
to you
additionally from an administrative side
uh you can see all the different people
who have access to
content you can see the different roles
so publishers versus
viewers so people can only consume act
uh content versus people who published
all the way down to administrators who
have additional privileges around
um you know changing assets that have
already been published
i can even go in here and you know lock
or edit the administrator roles for
this person so from a access content
or sort from an access perspective you
have full control over this
from not having to go into a config file
you also have visibility into the use of
your applications or the use of your
server
you can see how many people are actually
on your server
how many connections are being used how
much ram and cpu of your server has been
used you know is it getting hit a lot
or is it uh you know being used at a low
level
you also have you know your audit logs
you can actually see all the different
things that have happened different
events over time so you have this
visibility into things that are
occurring on your server
with that uh we have about 15 minutes
left so i do want to get into the demo
portion
uh the first idea here is i've taken
my existing code so this access the care
hospital dashboard which was created by
edgar one of the solution engineers here
at our studio
and this has been published on the
connect there's a couple things going on
here that i want to show you in terms of
this is actually
a flex dashboard setup so you'll have a
shiny runtime on top of that
so because it has a shiny runtime that
means you can re-execute our code on the
fly
so i can switch between states and it
will re-execute our code and give me
some type of new output
on the front end i actually have an html
widget so
this interactivity here doesn't require
the server back-end so this could be
shifted over into a pure our markdown
document
i'm focusing on this example because
it's a simple
kind of example the basic idea is how
many
hospitals you need per population and
you can see
that with our linear model here about
80.8 0.78 r
squared the idea here is that as your
population increases you need more
hospitals so i'm going to be using this
example for the rest of my rmr time
examples but wanted to start with the
shiny example because this is shiny
you have access to the shiny runtime in
terms of the server itself
so you can go in here and specify uh
specific settings or
you just use the server defaults about
how to scale up this application or how
performant you want to be
so maybe you want you know it to idle
out and kind of close down pretty
quickly because once people stop using
it you want it to free up
compute on your server so you could go
in here for the shiny portion
and change all these different factors
but as i mentioned before we really want
to focus on our markdown but i just want
to show you that you have this ability
to change the runtime and when you click
on the runtime if it's a shiny
application it has these options
so i mentioned a little bit about html
widgets and i want to show you this
specific example that is kind of a hello
world more basic example
of html widgets plus crosstalk so
in this case there isn't a shiny runtime
so there's no server on the backend this
is just the html front end
so in this case i can actually filter
and change
my graph here um without having to rerun
our code
i've published this out and the only
thing that's being changed is html
and javascript on the front end so all
this interactivity i have built in
doesn't require a running shiny example
and you can even click here and filter
into small examples
of you know filtering the graph itself
so basically the idea here that i'm
setting up is that your
markdown could be built as a shiny
component or
you could build it out here with just
front-end interactivity
so going back to our access to care by
state example maybe you take that shiny
application and you're like oh well
i really just want to send out reports
to each of the
state governors and say like hey you
know your state is doing well or doing
poorly
and how many hospitals it has for user
population
so you take that same uh our markdown
based report
change the output to pdf and publish
this onto connect as well so now it's
hosted
it's got authenticated access and only
people who are allowed to see it can
actually come in here and access it
you still have a table you still have a
map because it's pdf there's no
interactivity it's just a static
document
importantly if i go in here into the
connect portion
i can see that the access of who can
actually edit this document so
who can change it uh only these four
people so edgar would actually push it
out
and then the three collaborators but
i've made it where anyone can access or
view this document without login
required i could make this to where
users specifically would have to log in
or only to specific users or groups like
say the administration team
or the exact team all the way down to
just the collaborators and the owner of
the document
additionally because it's not a shiny
application there's no run time so
there's no
r code being executed continuously
but because it's an r markdown document
i could still schedule this output to
occur at a specific time interval so i
could
say yes i see this application or this
report
i want it to run once a week for
eternity you know
every week it updates the data and
creates a new report
so i want to see that here on connect so
i can schedule the report to occur
every wednesday like today i'll have it
run weekly
on wednesday and i want to publish an
output i can also send an email after
the update
so not only does it publish it here on
to connect it would actually send it to
all the collaborators all the viewers or
or whoever you wanted to go out to
so kind of having this option of having
it be on connect or in your inbox
additionally beyond just kind of the
pure i just want to see this report
there was a lot more states here in the
shiny application besides just
california
because this is a parameterized r
markdown i can actually go in here on
the left tab
and change the parameters within connect
rerun the report and regenerate the
output
so i could change it to texas colorado
uh wherever i wanted to be
rerun the report and it will regenerate
that
i'll go into the html widget example to
kind of show that because it's a little
more fun
to have the interactivity so pdf is
great
but maybe we want to still have some
interactivity so now this is still
in our markdown document so there's no
shiny run time
but if i go in here i can still get
front-end interactivity
so what is the user population there how
many hospitals are expected
versus how many do they have i have a
data table down here in terms of i can
actually click through
and adjust this data table i could sort
by population
alphabetically number of hospitals all
this interactivity that's built in here
and kind of i don't have to use
computational resources around the shiny
application
you can still create a wonderful shiny
application around this but just giving
you this alternative
importantly you have the same idea you
could still schedule this report to run
you can see i have it where it's running
every monday it actually sends me an
email every monday so that i get this
updated report
additionally you can save different
versions so i live in texas so maybe i
want to always come back in here and see
taxes so i can actually save
a personal report for myself just come
in here
and use texas or go back to california
or just go back to the default that we
see before
and again because it's parameterized i
can go in here
and give it to someone who doesn't know
how to code at all in r
but once to see this report for delaware
so they can actually come in here run
the report connect will execute the code
rerun the report regenerate it renet it
all this and put it back
here into your viewport and this person
can then
self-service you know provide their own
analytics or create their own reporting
so you can take your data science you
know model or your data science
product that you've created here create
a report around it
and then share that widely within your
organization
uh including people who can code or
people who cannot code
so same idea it's changed the title um
it's created a new map here
for delaware a lot less counties here in
delaware
and then again it's got the same kind of
interactivity around the data table
um yeah so you've got this parameter
rotation
parameterization option so i could save
this
uh but i don't i'm not interested in
that i want to keep texas as my favorite
additionally you can take kind of this
similar our markdown report and
knit it out to a zarin gin presentation
so same idea you have
a xy coordinate of your hospitals versus
user population
you can look at the linear relationship
between the two
and then actually output the model
around that so maybe this would be more
interesting for your data scientist
as opposed to your executive team but
similarly this is built purely from our
markdown report
that's then generated out to azangan
html
and javascript presentation
it could still be you know a scheduled
to rerun
um or primaritized as needed
additionally because connect also allows
for publishing from jupiter notebooks
you can take the same data
you know run similar ideas in terms
you're looking at population versus
county
level and how many hospitals there are
and this is actually a jupiter notebook
that's been published onto our studio
connect so
maybe you have a lot of people working
in r maybe a lot of people working in r
and in python like this is primarily
python code
you could have python integrated into
our markdown through reticulate
or you can actually publish directly
from your jupyter notebook
onto connect through the jupiter plugin
so really making it a widely used tool
kind of regardless of the the language
you're putting into the table
moving a little bit beyond the concept
of all these different reports
maybe doing some things that would be
more along the lines of a little bit of
data engineering
or kind of more less kind of
interesting but very necessary and
useful uh
ideas so here we're doing an extract
transform load or
etl script this is run as an our
markdown document
it's running some r code you know
generating some type of output
creating some portfolio ideas around
stock prices
and then it's actually writing this out
to a table within our database
so the idea here that you could take
this etl script
as an markdown document and rather than
having to you know run a cron job
or you know manually do all this stuff
you can just have it automatically
update
once a week once a day every hour once a
month
however you want to schedule it you
could have this etl job
rerun and prepare your data for you so
first thing in the morning it's ready to
go
and you don't have to go in and do this
manually so again
freeing you up to do kind of the more
intellectually rigorous stuff within
your data science environment
as opposed to spending a lot of time
re-running things manually
additionally kind of taking something
still within the
reporting space or the kind of our
markdown
output uh creating this report that's
rich
and you look at this and you know it's a
useful report it's got some front-end
air activity
again uh no shiny here but you have the
ability to zoom in
and drill down kind of at specific
levels see
the the model fit here in terms of the
local
line fitting and then how much you know
are we spending on customers versus
items and visits
regardless of the content here the idea
is that this is all built from
our markdown document so again you can
do your parameterization
and specify different levels you could
have you know 10 different inputs or
however many different inputs you wanted
to
maybe you want to change the segment to
a different part of user population or a
different group
or a different time period
additionally this actually has a link to
download the report as an excel
file so people are still going to use
spreadsheet software
kind of within an organization it's
going to happen but at least at this
point you've generated it
programmatically so you have full
visibility into you've created a report
with code so you know exactly why and
how it was created
and now you have a file that can be
shared widely
that you have kind of visibility into
additionally and again kind of hitting
on the same note i could send an email
about this
automatically or i could send it to
myself manually
so kind of taking this idea of being
able to share it widely
within my organization either in the
inbox or on connect
now the exciting part for me is let me
pull this over real quick
so this same report is now in my inbox
so you can see that this is html output
it's almost identical
to uh the report on connect so
this is just in my inbox i said to
myself last night um it has the same
idea where you still have you know a
graph
that you could look at you have a full
you know rich text format
table uh you can go back to connect and
click on it
and it even pastes in the excel file
here in your email
so rather than having doing this manual
request and responding
uh directly to you know ad hoc request
you're able to
have this done either automatically or
programmatically and send out these very
rich emails
so i hopefully that was it was
interesting to y'all uh we're running
out of time here with a couple minutes
left so i'm just going to hit on a
couple of the last slides and points
a lot of these examples came from the
solutions.ourstudio.com website
specifically if you go here to the by
industry healthcare
access the care portion but really
importantly this has a lot of our best
practices for
using both our studio professional
products and generally a lot of how
we're thinking about using
r and r plus python kind of in your
environment to do data science at scale
so kind of giving you examples scripts
or examples of how
you can approach this on connect as well
as just kind of thinking about it in
general
lastly if you are interested in kind of
learning more about connect you can go
here to the rstudio.com
product connect there's a free 45-day
evaluation
where you can try it on your own server
or on the cloud or you can download
pre-configured quick start where you
just install a virtual machine
and then run it on that with that i'll
get back into the slides real quick
i appreciate uh everyone joining me here
for today
so kind of the the real core concept
here is that connect can help you get
started
or help you level up so whether you're
kind of just getting started
in your long data science journey you
have a small team and you really just
want to start you know having a more
robust data science environment
connect is ready for your team to start
publishing things
and creating assets out there for your
team to actually have insights around
alternatively if you have a more robust
data science environment
you're starting to use continuous
integration you want high availability
scaling hundreds or thousands of users
connect is still ready to serve you so
across this entire spectrum
connect is a ready product for you to
help level up your data science
environment
and this is really hyped upon or harped
upon here by sean who's the product
manager here at rstudio
um i see a lot of our users feel like
imposters when production comes up
lots of tools and lingos out there but
trust me if you fit a model the rest
doesn't have to be hard
with our studio connect you can take the
hard work you've already done
on your core data science work and take
that and take it to the next level
with our markdown or shiny or plumber
apis all publishing on the connect
with that i'll leave you with these last
few slides or
links which are the same links from the
beginning basically additional webinars
for you to take a look at specific to
administrating our studio as a whole
model management and putting models in
production using rstudio connect
and then shiny production more about the
principles practices and tools by joe
chang
additionally kelly o'brien will be
giving the third webinar in this webinar
series
and she'll be talking a little bit more
about interactivity and production
including a bit of shiny lastly again
we do have 45-day free evaluation of pro
products so if you want to try something
out
or you can always book a call with us to
talk about our studio connect through
rstudio.you can bookme
thanks with that i will go back to
questions
looks like one here from steve when a
regular markdown is on connect can the
code be modified and run right there in
the browser like a jupiter notebook
so the r markdown itself is executed
through parameters
so you would still be if you wanted to
work within interactivity
or interactively you'd be using it
either in the ide
so that could be through rcd or server
pro or your desktop id
but really kind of the idea of connect
is that you've published both the
finished product as well as the source
code
so you can still run and update things
through parameters but you want to have
kind of a static
input there or some kind of static
source code i guess
for small teams or their pricing options
that get you started other than 45 days
free
so uh for kind of aiming at the academic
as well as small
businesses yes we do have academic
discounts
um as well as small business discounts
depending upon your revenue
so absolutely reach out to us via sales
rstudio.com and we're happy to generate
kind of have a discussion around what
you're looking for and work around
kind of the budget you have
um and it looks like all the rest of the
questions were
answered so i think we're good there but
i appreciate y'all's
attention today and have a good rest
your week